here's the big breaking news as of 7:51
p.m. CNBC Sam bankman freed found guilty
on all seven criminal fraud counts the
month-long trial of Z bman freed wrapped
on Thursday uh say a jury has found him
guilty on all seven criminal uh criminal
accounts the former FTX CEO faces a
maximum sentence of 115 years in prison
bankman free the 31-year-old son 3
31-year-old son of two Stanford at legal
Scholars and graduate of MIT has pleaded
had pleaded not guilty to charges
including wire fraud Securities fraud
etc etc ET we get all that stuff the
trial ended blah blah blah we get it
okay all this this is just like the the
bits and Bobs we don't care about who
was this guy what was he doing he was a
big Democrat donor yeah and there's a
lot of speculation that he was basically
using these schemes to help fund
Democrat politicians yeah he donated to
over 300 uh political Campa and directly
to the DNC there's another big
conspiracy theory that the money that
was going through Ukraine was coming
back through him to the DNC that was the
big that was the big conspiracy theory I
don't know if it's been proven yet or
not but it wouldn't surprise me at all
at all yeah there I can't remember what
that was there was something a man it's
been so long like we're seriously uh
getting ready for the show and like oh
look at this big you know vote vot voter
uh cheating story and then boom breaking
news bankman freed is is found guilty on
all counts but but it is a fact that he
was this big Democrat donor the money he
was making what was he like he wasn't
that well off and then he started FTX
and all of a sudden he skyrocketed and
net worth and capital yeah billions and
then he immediately starts funding a
bunch of democrat politicians now I'll
just I'll be nice I shouldn't be but
I'll be nice that doesn't implicate any
of these politicians but it certainly
shows that the people at least some of
the most powerful people here it is who
are funding these politicians are
criminals who are using dirty methods of
funding these politicians and then I've
got questions about how act blue
operates James Keef with the OMG Media
Group did a big story about uh and this
is coming from them that money from
China was flowing through act
blue I got a lot of questions about what
what these people are up to you that
wouldn't surprise me either I'd gladly
trade uh SBF for for uh Ross brick today
to the federal prison we should get Ross
out there he he created e-commerce
website that did he though uh did he
actually create it yeah uh I mean maybe
for for people who don't aren't familiar
the uh he's he's dread pirate Roberts to
well they yeah they say that but he did
I mean he was the creator of of silk
road but he they don't know if he was
there was several dread pirate Roberts
um but they don't know if he was the one
that had to do with the the murder For
Hire stuff they just brought it up in
court dragged him through the mud and
then dropped all those charges and then
put him in prison for two and a half
life sentences this right this is the
Silk Road this is where people were
buying and trading a bunch of stuff
whether it was legal or not and uh the
username was dread pirate Roberts so one
of them yeah one of them the argument
was he he makes this or or someone made
it and they pass it off to someone else
and they just share this name you guys
have seen The Princess Bride oh yeah the
truth is I am not the dread pirate
robberts yes exactly the real dread
pirate Roberts died years ago it was
really genius I mean if you think about
it the way they they ran that but but he
said in in in prison for two and a half
life sentences for an e-commerce website
and nothing more really I mean that's
basically what it was Tucker Carlson me
to went to meet Julian Sange I did see
that I have not w i mean the episode
hasn't come out yet but yeah I saw that
he went to meet with him but I don't
know if I don't know if they're filming
anything I don't know if he's able to
film in prison God I hope they let him
yeah that'd be interesting but either
way I'm curious if y'all think this is a
blip this guy getting caught getting
busted or I think this may be a
component that we've seen of the
faltering of the uh Neo uh the neoc
corporate liberal neocon neolib
establishment it's it's it schemes are
failing I mean some people like to say
since Epstein got taken down it started
to look like it's unraveling perhaps I
don't know maybe this was their attempt
at creating some kind of alternate
creepy International funding scheme no
idea but when you see stories like this
it certainly is a grain of sand at least
in the Heap of all of these like
surreptitious plans and like shady Deals
they used to do are getting exposed
every day I mean you look at the Biden
stuff they're not saying $40,000 went to
Joe or something like that you like more
money is being found Trac to him you I
kind of feel good about it I don't know
what do you think I I definitely think
that this is is just one of many I don't
think this is the only instance like
this and you know these people
absolutely hate us and and want us sick
and tired and dead mostly um no but and
these are the people that are funding
them I think it's probably going to be
if the mainstream media can they'll spin
it to be like this is why you should
fear crypto this is what the issue is
Never Trust crypto don't look for
alternative currency people who push
alternative currencies are you know
scamming you or whatever else they'll
try to avoid the fact that he was
ultimately in the camp of the DNC and
that's what I am concerned about they're
only going to break they're only going
to break the altcoins cuz the Bitcoin
Community is way too strong yeah but
what he was doing is running an exchange
the crypto themselves are legit some of
them are extremely I believe that but I
think the average American is not so
well versed in in crypto to understand
the the differences so we got to get
them more well versed I think that's
great but you are now racing the
mainstream media who's trying to protect
the DNC right they're going to say no no
it's not that he was influ taking money
from Democrats or trying to influence
anything political it's this technology
that you're scared of and I say that as
a full-on technophobe right if if you
are afraid of crypto you don't really
understand the difference between an
exchange and the coins and all currency
or whatever else you're going to say
this guy scammed a lot of people and the
mainstream media embc says that I can't
trust them and that's what they want you
to believe they don't want you to make
the political connection well then we
need to be ready with the
counternarrative that that's fine just
bitcoin's much safer they can't stop
crypto they can't stop crypto because
too many people are just sitting there
waiting for their get-rich quick scheme
because they don't quite understand how
it works works but uh I think you know
when I when I talk to regular people who
don't get it the only thing the average
person I like when I talk to regular
people I typically hear first and
foremost do you think it's going to go
up because everybody remembers when it
jumps to like 20K and people got rich
overnight everybody remembers when it
jumped to 60k and people got rich
overnight and everybody is just waiting
for that opportunity to jump on the next
wave and then it goes back down I mean
it went to like 60 it went down to what
like 17 yeah but zoom out it's never
actually gone down I mean we've it's had
a pullback kaboom Spike Spike Spike and
well it's because the way Bitcoin
operates I think uh we're due for a
having soon aren't we I'm not sure I
heard that I heard that last week about
that I just don't track the schedule
next April or something something like
that and and that uh uh I'm not going to
pretend to know what that means but a
lot of people are like oh boy get ready
because basically what this means is the
super simple not I I don't run a Bitcoin
company but the super simple version is
the amount of energy to produce uh uh
the amount of energy required per per
Bitcoin is going to double yeah block
rewards are cut in half basically and
that means if it costs let's just let's
just do dry units 100 units of energy to
create one Bitcoin after it's cut in
half it's going to be 200 units of
energy for one Bitcoin meaning your cost
will double and you're going to have to
charge more no one's going to want to
sell like for this reason that's
basically forcing the prices to go up
not to mention it's it it it it's the
attrition of Bitcoin itself yeah
specifically in April 2024 the block
rewards will decrease from 6.25 to 3.125
did you what was this Max Kaiser offered
Alex Jones 10,000 Bitcoins last week or
whatever did you see the TW the Twitter
of him going we're not selling he's like
screaming on stage we're not selling
wait wait wait he so the story is Max
offered Alex Jones 10,000 Bitcoins 300
something million dollars by today's
standard
and Alex like didn't care and like lost
it or something said whatever and then
Max told him I'll give you another
10,000 if you can answer five Bitcoin
questions and Alex couldn't do it and
apparently they were like not
complicated questions but their
questions like basically if you're in
Bitcoin you knew right and uh he offered
him $300 million well that's not even
enough to cover half of his fines
unfortunately you know no it a third
yeah that's the funny thing like if he
actually gave him the crypto it' be gone
in two seconds sees it by the way I did
a show Chase Geer this morning I love
Chase Infowars that's what made me think
about it early this morning check it out
um also when you're wondering is crypto
going to go up you also got to ask
yourself is the US dollar going to go
down yeah because it's they're inversely
proportionate we really need to be we
need to get out of this like is it going
to go up and down like narrative and
start we got we got to figure out a way
to like uh pass this this dream of mass
adoption because it's going to be so
important if we ever look if if the the
central banking system ever fails and
it's not about when it's about if I
believe that it will eventually no you
mean about if it's when yeah that's yeah
that's what I meant yeah that's what I
meant I I mixed that up but yeah
absolutely when it when it happens um
you know if you're on something that
already has a framework worked out
you're going to feel a lot less blood
than the normal person who has no other
Investments I could see like Amazon Jeff
Bezos just being like now you can pay
with Bitcoin I could see something like
that that's I mean that's that's a part
of mass adoption and the more people
that accept Bitcoin the the the closer
we get to that mass adoption the more
that people start buying Bitcoin the
more Bitcoin stabilizes and you stop
seeing these these these
people it as what it it's it's a you
know money it's your you know when you
can start making purchases with it it's
it's Salvador yeah and and people in
Salvador are doing great things I mean
the economy has been pretty well off
since they've done that me though if you
look at the entire crypto Market all of
them according to coinmarketcap.com the
entire Market's $1.3 trillion that's
like nothing compared to the US us could
print that up and buy it all it's just a
matter of finding it but like it doesn't
seem stable to me that it's that little
be that moved around by the global
governments why do you disagree I just I
don't think that they will I don't I
think that they want they want full
control over the blockchain right and so
that's why they're going to push cbdcs
because those they'll have the
opportunity to shut down your money on
the spot you know what I mean they could
take if he said the wrong thing on the
internet they could shut down your money
boom they want that kind of control they
don't have that kind of control of
Bitcoin uh but they could easily get it
I I disagree I just don't think they I
don't think I don't think that they I
don't think they care enough about it to
do that I think that they want to find a
way to but there's also other there's
other ways to have Anonymous Bitcoin
exchange as well you know level two and
and lightning Network and stuff like
that too it's becoming more Anonymous
it's not it's not becoming more like
government friendly as we as time goes
on so the issue is once there
is look it's it's really this simple New
York City says if you accept Bitcoin
from our band list then we are going to
find you $10,000 a day and we already
saw what happened with masks they will
all immediately bend the knee so you so
you can't stop someone from having
Bitcoin sure but government can stop you
from being able to use it but Miami
actually is encouraging it and what they
and what they'll do is if they really
want to ban you they'll they they they
will issue a mandate to all terminals at
stores these addresses are are the ban
list and they'll argue these are
terrorists and criminals and if you
facilitate through these so what'll
happen then is smaller level businesses
will say can we get a can we get
something that will instantly add these
addresses to our terminals cuz we can't
track all this a company will be like
we're terminal safe make sure you're not
funding terrorism upload our government
approved uh uh you know ban list and
you're only Banning people who are
terrorists and then they got right well
that's also why we need like government
officials that are going to like ban
chainalysis and and like you know uh
Bitcoin trackers and stuff that the
federal government use now get there the
federal government will absolutely but
the decentral the decentralized
revolution is going to eventually find a
way around it whether whether it's a new
kind of web development or something
it's going to come along that will
continue I feel like people make this
mistake with a lot of things politics
and Technology are not as relevant as
culture and morals and so when you look
at everything in this country the people
are complaining about I'm like yeah our
culture has completely decayed our our
morals are gone and you've got people
who are willing to lie cheat and steal
to take whatever they want because they
don't care of course not completely
though I know what you mean I'm watching
the I want to save a little bit this
this for later because I was watching
some of the trial the Minnesota uh Trump
hearing on the 14th Amendment and we
know what's going to happen with this
the judges don't care what's right they
care about winning for their ideology
yeah they're partisan now I and so right
I'm like nothing your technology doesn't
matter okay the guy with the unless
there a civil war New York City will
simply say in a mandate if you accept
from these Bitcoin addresses we will
find you
$10,000 and every business will drop to
their knees and beg daddy government
please make it easy for us to not not
accidentally give facilitate these
transactions but if you did that you
could send the person could send their
Bitcoin from that address to a different
address and then and all they have to do
is say any any Bitcoin that transfers
from this address to the next is now non
Persona nonr and then you're going to be
like dude are you on the list I don't
don't don't screw my Bitcoin bro I can't
trade with
you be like shoot yourself in the foot
if if a if an economy did that to
themselves they'd be like they'd be in
the dust they are trying to push for
stuff like that currently I guarantee
you by today's standards with AI and
machine learning they can easily create
algorithms tracking active blockchain
transactions they know who you are they
know what you're buying and even if you
create a new wallet they will know
because they're spying on your phone
when they're going to know if the
addresses are being operated from the
same device where it's being where the
transactions are they're going to know
it's you yeah but you can get around
that too you can get around the device
stuff you can use tour and all kinds of
different you are not going to be able
to beat an AI
you will you you are not going to walk
into a McDonald's and be like my burner
phone's going to beat the AI it's go and
you're going to go what why isn't it
working I just bought a burner phone and
put money because they track they're
tracking you put your phone in the
freezer put under running water ditch it
there there there's cameras everywhere I
mean you look at these Amazon stores my
my my point is it is possible that we we
find a way to overcome this my I'm I'm
just saying well they're actively
working on ways to overcome it now I
mean that's you know the lightning
network was part of that so there needs
to be a cultural shift in what we are
willing to accept and tolerate right now
because humans absolutely Americans
especially tolerate being spied on and
we we are walking we are zombie walking
into social credit scores sure I don't
disagree with you at all I I I
absolutely 100% think that America has
headed toward social credit and I think
they're going to Market it as something
that's good for you right it's
convenient I think about that there's
this girl on Instagram chip girl and
she's got like whatever in her hand and
she can pay for stuff and this is her
whole social media influencer you know
I'm sure she talks about other things
but the fact that she is chipped is a
big deal and it becomes glamorous right
she's also constantly showing off her
luxury goods it's going to be part of
the cbdcs though is what it's going it's
it's all going to come down chipping is
not not going to be a thing at least for
now and the reason is rejection so uh
when when you put a chip under your skin
they can reject it yeah yeah people can
reject it and so that's not foolproof
some people will be fine some people
will not be fine uh it'll be part of
your cbdc wallet what I mean is I mean
they'll market social credit store as
like well it's so convenient for you
it's easier it's faster to do things I
think people won't see it coming because
it'll be misrepresented to them for what
it is right sure sure my my my theory is
that what happens is is we're going to
have a financial crisis we're going to
have a banking collapse maybe only uh
20% of the US Banks collapse that's a
huge percentage it is a huge but but
it's not 100 it's not 30 it's going to
be at least 20 for sure 20% and then
what happens let's say you're uh give me
a give me a b it's not too big but big
enough I mean I don't know it's tough
right I mean uh let's do we're we're out
here we got what do we got uh PNC PNC
sure PNC I see I see them in PA a little
bit smaller but they're still kind of
big a bank like that fails and then what
happens is everybody who's got this
account says my business the payroll for
my employees right look my business we
had 500,000 in the account we I got to
pay my weight my my server staff I got
to buy new pizza rolls what am I going
to do my bank account's gone federal
government immediately snaps their
fingers within a couple days they say we
are bail out the American people this is
not about big business this bank went
under we're mad but we are going to
ensure all of the money for all of these
people 100% not up to 250,000 like uh
FDIC says we're going to ensure all of
it rest assured small business you will
pay your employees tomorrow simply
download cbdc at Google play.com and
download fed dollar oh God and they're
going to say in order to get access to
your account input your social security
number your account number and your
information into the into cbdc app and
you will get the US dollar equivalent of
fedcoin I'll tell you right now if if if
cbdcs had already been a thing during
the coid crisis the pass the passports
would have been a thing let me slow down
for everybody Central Bank digital
currencies yes correct because I know a
lot of people are like cbdc we're going
too fast you're in the jargon now
Central Bank digital currency the idea
is Bitcoin is decentralized and
everything explained about how they'll
try to take it over is what they'll have
to try to do if the Federal government
or the FED can launch a central bank
digital currency like fedcoin they will
have instant access and control to
everything and then you get social
credit scores but they don't need to
tell you they're rolling out social
credit scores they will just exist yeah
you'll get a notification on your app
and it will be like we're concerned
about some activity on your on on your
external profiles they've already
introduced the idea of off-platform
behavior all your Healthcare stuff's
going to be on there too I mean that's
oh yeah that's the scary part you'll
have no more privacy it just sounds like
setting up for a black market if they
try and do stuff like that people get
pissed off they don't want a pissed off
population right but but black market
doesn't matter okay like you know
Sheamus makes this point about abortion
when the left says yeah but if you ban
abortion there'll be Black Market
abortions and it was right and most of
it will still be illegal and that will
stop most of it great there's always
going to be illegal activity that's
that's that right
so the the the the concerning thing I
suppose you're going to have this app
and we've already seen on Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube you can be banned
for what they call off platform Behavior
right yep the cbdc app is going to have
terms and conditions and it's going to
say you agree that if you use this app
you can't do these things and the people
who are in a crisis whose bank accounts
have been you know have collapsed and
are gone they're going to sign anything
yeah oh what do you do they you erased
your business overnight oh no and it's
no one's fault the bank just failed do
you remember PayPal trying to do that
trying to find people for off platform
Behavior yes they Tred to find them and
this is these are all Tri instead they
just ban people who do stuff they don't
like they they they they have this
provision on PayPal it's
$2500 for like some kind of hate speech
provision they will fine you they'll
fine you for saying naughty words not
just not just like not take your money I
mean they will fine you they will give
you a fine if you have no money in your
PayPal you will be negative $25 here
here so the crisis scenario is scary but
how about the tax benefit scenario where
they say we're rolling out a a a a
Federal Banking App they're going to say
something like these predatory uh
lending companies and banks are are
charging an arm and a leg why is it that
if you're poor the bank charges you
money you look at your bank account
you've only got 25 bucks the next day
you look at negative 15 they charged you
they they charged you for that because
you didn't have enough in your account
now you're negative now you owe them
money but if you're rich they pay you
that is unfair the post office will be
opening Holdings accounts for yes right
for all Americans download the post
office app it is a no fee Bank bank
account for you to the American people
with interest rates no more overdraft
charges now you've got a federal
government banking system you download
the app you agree to their terms of
service don't say naughty words and
they're monitoring every single
transaction you make thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at
timcast.net next
time